hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
fast cost effective and high throughput
solutions
for dna assembly i am michelle ashton of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by beckman culture life
sciences
for more information on our sponsor
please visit www
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any tiny one during the presentation
to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
so hayla beck
the echo commercial product manager of
genomics at beckman culture life
sciences
and tom speedy the field application
manager
for synthetic biology at integrated dna
technologies
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biographies tab at the
top of your screen
so hayla and tom you may now begin your
presentations
thank you michelle hello everyone and
thank you for attending this talk
today we are going to talk about fast
cost effective and how to put solutions
for dna assembly
but let me first give you a quick
introduction to our company
betterment culture life sciences was
founded by celtic professor
arnold beckman in 1935 and joined
danahour corporation in 2011.
we make and support a range of solutions
from liquid handlers
to cell counters to centrifuges and flow
cytometers
along with that we manufacture and
support a range of high quality reagents
and consumables to ensure delivering
high performance in variety of assays
from genomics to cell viability and
philosophy
we also manufacture a variety of lab
there including tips and plates
now focusing on topic of today's talk
which is setting up gene assemblies
as we know these techniques play an
important role in a lot of applied
fields
for example in faster vaccine
development for rapidly evolving viruses
or generating new antibodies for
therapeutic purposes
which as we know are some of the very
hot topics these days
however as we know making a successful
product through using gene assembly
techniques
involve trying thousands of different
combinations of gene fragments coming
together
through different gene assembly methods
some of the common methods being used
are golden gate
gibson nab builder or other commercial
and custom methods
but no matter which method you use as we
discussed
thousands of different combinations need
to go through
a high throughput cycle of build design
test and learn with many points of
failures
therefore it would be essential to have
a solution
which can reduce the assembly and qc
costs and also transfer reagents and
fragments
from anywhere in the source plate to any
well in the destination plate rapidly
the good news is beckman culture life
sciences
offers an acoustic liquid handler called
echo 525
which is a tipless and non-contact
liquid handler
echo transfers microliter to nano litre
range of volume
down to 25 nanoliter very accurately and
precisely
it has a fast flow rate of up to six
microliter per second
so what that means for example is
to transfer 2 microliter from a 384
source plate
to a 3 to 4 destination plate it takes
less than 4 minutes
because of these fast and accurate
transfers echo enables reduced assembly
and qc reaction volume
and therefore reducing the cost while
maintaining data quality or even
improving them
so how does the echo work
the heart of echo technology is a
transducer
that generates low energy ultrasounds
which are focused on the meniscus of the
liquid
in the source well to shoot 25 nanoliter
droplets
to the wells of a destination plate
which is inverted on top of the source
plate
echo uses a unique technology called
dynamic fluid analysis
which what it means is adjusting the
transfer parameters
in real time for variety of fluids so
various samples such as
dna rna enzymes master mixes can all be
transferred at different concentrations
without any user calibration
all user needs to do is choose the right
calibration from a short list of
available calibration echo has a very
easy
and user-friendly software in which a
user would upload a pick list
to dictate the transfer pattern from
anywhere in the source to anywhere in
the destination
as mentioned these transfers are fast
for example a tip-based liquid handler
may take
six seconds to do a belt of well
transfer but for echo this would be less
than a second
and therefore the combination of
software and hardware make echo
a great set for gene assembly workflows
echo comes in variety of flavors
so far i talked about the echo 525 which
transfers 25 nanoliter droplets of
aqueous fluid
in the range of nanoliter to mitral
liter
we also offer echo 650 and echo 655
which transfer 2.5 nanoliter droplets of
both
dmso and aqueous solutions and are also
compatible
with storage tubes which means that you
don't need to transfer the samples from
storage tubes to a plate before
transferring on echo
and you can directly transfer from tubes
echo 655 is much faster than echo 650
here at batman we also offer modular
flexible and
scalable integration solutions called
access systems
for walk away and high throughput
workflows
so let's look at the typical gene
assembly workflow
echo can help in pulling of the
fragments setting up the gene assembly
reactions in smaller volumes
and even spotting the culture after
transformation to get the single
colonies
and also help with any optional qc steps
such as
colony qpcr or ngs as well as
any downstream functional testing to
miniaturize
and optimize those assays for example a
txt reaction that requires lots of
optimization
let's look at an example
recently we did an application note with
neb which is available on our website
we miniaturized the assembly reaction
volumes for nab builder hifi kit using
echo 525 liquid handler
fragments were ordered from idt in echo
source plates
so they were ready to go on echo when
arrived in mail
these reaction volumes were reduced from
20 microliter done manually
to 500 nanoliter on echo
so the volumes that are reduced on echo
are shown on this table from four
microliter down to 500 nanoliter total
reaction volume
for the 500 nanoliter reaction only for
1.25 centimole of each fragment piece
was used
therefore there is a lot of cost savings
on the reagents
after one hour 50 degrees celsius
incubation
the e coli competence cells were added
for example for the 500 nanoliter
reaction
12.5 microliter of the e coli cells
were added directly into the pcr plate
so now we are at least a step of the
workflow the transformation is done
and it's time to do the colony spotting
or the cultural spotting to get the
single colonies
echo can be very helpful in spotting
these cultures
in a dense format and save on a lot of
lv agar petri dishes that would have
been generated otherwise
did you know that echo can create
masterpieces
fajitas forecast jaspoka's lab at new
york university
have used their echo to create these
beautiful art pieces by dispensing
colored east
on sbs lv agar plates you can see more
amazing work like this on eastart.org
now back to our workflow we are at the
qcstep which can be optional in some
high throughput labs
to do either colony qpcr or ngs
library prep
so echo can be of great help
miniaturizing and
automating colony qpcr setups the
colonies are live in license buffer in
an
echo source plate primeram probes can be
ordered in
echo source plates from idt and master
mix
baby dispense from a reservoir source
plate
then echo will set up the qpcr reactions
in a fraction of volume
and therefore cost and then data will be
analyzed
a typical data from an experiment like
that
is shown here you can easily tell from
the amplification curve
whether a junction is missed and not
formed
or if the consort has been successful
like the one on top
so the coloring qpcr can be a very fast
and cost effective
effective way of using the gene assembly
workflows as you know an
echo can make it even more cost
effective and faster
to look at a typical cost saving for
such workflow offered by echo
this is an example from one of our
customers they reduced their reaction
volumes from 10 microliter
to one microliter total volume of qpcr
reaction
and therefore reduced their reagents
volumes accordingly 10 times
between the savings on the reagents and
tips
they had eightfold lift costs per sample
another way of doing qpcr for
constructs would be doing next-gen
sequencing
to get that single nucleotide resolution
for the whole construct for example
in a typical workflow for example for
nextera xt from illumina
a traditional liquid handler such as
biomat i series
can prepare the plasmid mini press and
then
echo can set up the fragmentation and
pcr setups for the library prep
while reducing the reaction volumes up
to 100 volts
after the pcr from labs we'll do
individual bit cleanups using a biomark
i series and then go to one
step super fast pulling and
normalization using echo
please note that echo unlike click-based
liquid handlers
can pull and normalize based on the
quant data
in the same step and this will save a
lot of time
and save on an intermediate dilution
step
some labs decide to not do individual
bit cleanup
and pull directly directly after pcr
using the echo
and echo can do that also really fast
the customers at
amerispy technologies have reduced the
reaction volumes
using echo up to 100 fold by going from
50 microliter to 500 nanometers
an example of a cost savings is shown
here by an example
from one of our customers they have been
able to
miniaturize their nab builder construct
building
40 volts and to have 40 volts reduction
in cost
from 18 to less than a dollar and for
the nextera
xd and did cleanup step they have been
able to reduce tenfold
some customers are happy with just
10-fold saving
and not pushing the miniaturization any
further to not worry about the
environmental aspects such as
evaporation so it's the decision of the
lab
another great example of echo being used
in common gene assembly kits to
miniaturize the reaction volume is shown
by a
paper in patrick kai and his group
published in journal of laboratory
automation in 2016.
as shown in the graph on the left the
gibson assembly reactions will
miniaturize
from 20 microliter being set up manually
as control
to one microliter down to 50 nanoliter
using echo
the interesting thing to see is the
assembly efficiency has actually
increased going down from 20 microliter
to one microliter
and it stays the same at 500 nanometers
with the 20 microliter
so echo not only improves the assembly
efficiency by miniaturization but it can
also offer cost savings
another example is the golden gate
assemblies shown on the right
where the reaction volumes were
miniaturized from
7.5 microliter being set up manually
to one micro liter and below down to
50 nano liter on echo and as you can see
the
assembly efficiency has maximized at 500
nanoliter
reaction assembly along with the cost
savings that it offers
so this is not uncommon to see that
miniaturization of the reaction volumes
using echo actually improves the
efficiencies and data quality
authors mentioned that we envision that
acoustic dispensing will become an
instrumental technology in synthetic
biology
so far we talked about the cost savings
of echo through miniaturization of
reaction volumes
while offering even better assembly
efficiencies
but now i would like to highlight the
time savings that it offers
based on data from amazon technologies
and other customers
we can see that echo can make these
workflows
for example 15 hours faster
so for example in a traditional liquid
handler
on a traditional liquid handler an
assembly can take about
12 hours and that has been reduced to
only three hours on echo in amherst
biotechnologies
or a pulling and normalization can take
six hours on a traditional liquid
handler
and that can be reduced to 12 minutes
and this is data from another lab
so the time savings are also huge
besides the time
cost savings and data quality
to summarize the liquid handlers
involved in such workflows
while echo is essential part of the gene
assembly workflow to create
assemblies spot the colonies and set up
the qc reactions in a smaller reaction
volumes
there is a need for a larger volume
liquid handler such as biomax i-series
to add the competent cells and media to
do the transformation
and to do any colony picking many perth
and optional bead cleanups
now echo and biomic both are offered by
beckman culture life sciences so you can
come to us for one-stop shop
for all liquid handlers from nanoliter
to milliliter
and getting the application and
engineering support
for optimizing your workflows from one
vendor
i have shown how such systems can be
integrated together
for more walk away and high throughput
workflows in the pictures
the grouper arm of biomac will pass the
place between echo and biomac
i would like to highlight a code by dr
sunil chandran
vp of rnd at amersby technologies
is an extremely fast instrument a
significant savings in terms of time
we've been able to compress pipelines
that take about 12 hours to about 3
hours
here i have shown the access system
which is our waterway
integration solution with the robotic
arm and plate hotel
next one next to their echo
to summarize the key features and
benefits that we talked about in this
talk
echo by going to a small volumes down to
25
or 2.5 nanoliters depending on the model
can reduce in reagent cost and conserve
on precious samples
echo is a non-contact acoustic drop
ejection system
and therefore it can improve data
quality and sustainability through using
less plastics
it's a fast enable to any well transfer
and therefore it will reduce assembly
time from hours to minutes
and it also enables fast qc
here at batman culture life sciences we
provide a full portfolio of solutions
from instruments to reagents to
software and great field application
and service engineering support
thank you everyone for your attention we
really
look forward to hearing from you about
your simple to complex projects and
working with you
now i would like to pass it on to our
next presenter thomas speedy from idt
thank you sahela um thank you all for
joining us today and thank you to our
hosts
labyrinths and our sponsor beckman corta
life sciences
i'm pleased to present to you today on
our fast cost effective and high
throughput solutions
the dna assembly from integrated dna
technology
idt was founded over 30 years ago in
coralville iowa
and is the global leader in dna and rna
synthesis
we have a global operation
headquartered in coralville we have
research and development facilities
in california and a production facility
we have a brand new production facility
in north carolina
and our european operations are centered
in lublin and belgium
and our asia pacific operations in
singapore
we also have a variety of sales offices
around the world as well
we now have more than fifteen hundred
associates
and more than a hundred and thirty
thousand active customers
and to give you an idea of the scale of
our operations
we manufacture ninety thousand olivine
nuclear ties
and over 1 100 genes and gene fragment
products
per day this equates to over 112 million
bases
per month so integrated dna technologies
core products
are nucleotides and as i mentioned we
have over 30 years of industry leading
quality
and cost efficiency our founder joe
walder
realized that the cost and and quality
of oligonucleotides at that
time was was very high cost and very
poor quality
and therefore he started idt by offering
free oligonucleotides to academics
in return for them sending him their old
synthesizers
but over the years we have developed and
optimized all our technologies which
i'll come on to in just a moment
in addition to our core products we have
also built a range of other products
from those
for a variety of applications these
include as we're discussing today
synthetic biology
but also qpcr gene synthesis
ngs molecular biology genotyping
and various others as well
so to give you an example of some of the
innovative products that we've uh
made leveraging our expertise in dna
synthesis
here we see some examples from our prime
time qpcr
probes primers and assays to our x-gen
lockdown probes and blocking oligos for
ngs
we have a complete portfolio for crispr
our altar crisper reagents range from
design through enzymes and
guides into hdr enhancers
and single stranded templates for
efficient integration and we also have
our g blocks gene fragment products
which we're going to go into more detail
in just a second
we offer a variety of customized
solutions for your oligonucleotide
you can order single stranded or
double-stranded dna
in plates or tubes we also offer
oligopoles and primer mixes
and we offer to aliquot and provide
replicates
if required
idt continues to provide customers with
leading edge genomics products
as a result of our commitment to
sustainable growth and the vertical
integration of our products
idt we make all our own high-quality
chemical reagents
oligosynthesis in-house we develop our
own instrument platforms and engineering
solutions
we have scientists creating custom
software for our manufacturing processes
and our customer ordering portals
we also have a very strong team of
customer care associates
who provide a premier customer service
experience
in fact our net promoter score is 9.12
which
exceeds that of many of the world's most
renowned brands
our idt scientists have created
innovative products of the highest
quality
with industry leading quality control
capabilities
and we continue to develop these
offerings
so now i would like to discuss the
synthetic biology portfolio at idt
as sahala mentioned fundamental to
synthetic biology is the design
field test learn cycle and one of the
things that really excites me about
synthetic biology
is the way that numerous disciplines
have come together such as chemistry
computer science biology
engineering physics to provide solutions
in a range of areas such as biosensors
biomaterials
biofuels biomedicine including
diagnostics
and therapeutics by bioremediation
for food flavor fragrance and fine
chemicals
a really great example of this is a uk
synthetic biology company
called colorifics who have developed an
ethical
and sustainable technology for dying
textiles
they realized that the textile industry
processes were creating huge amount of
pollution
and through the use of synthetic biology
they have been able to engineer bacteria
and yeast to fix and color textiles
eliminating toxic waste and reducing
water
use by over 10 times in fact
i actually recently received some shirts
which have been dyed using the
colorifics technology
a purple id t-shirt where the color is
derived from silk cocoon
and a beige id t-shirt which is color is
derived from melanin
from gorillas idt fits into this
design build test learn cycle providing
the tools for the build component
we have a range of products all the way
through from our oligonucleotides to
opals
our dna fragments through to our clonal
genes
and then our pathways group for
more custom solutions and finally our
single stranded megamas
all of these synthetic biology products
are built from our ultramar oligonuclear
type
these are used to assemble the gene
fragments including our g-blocks
our e-blocks and the new products that
i'm about to mention
in a moment we use these fragments to
assemble custom genes
and we use these genes to make the
single stranded megamas
as i mentioned we also have a custom
project team
who are willing to take on any projects
outside those
through our high throughput
manufacturing processes
so first i'd like to introduce the
e-blocks gene fragments
these have been made for speed they
typically ship
in one to three business days they're
available from 300 to 900 bases
and they're priced very competitively at
six cents per base
they're particularly suited to antibody
discovery
vaccine development high throughput
screening
and they're available in a variety of
shipping formats including
the beckman quarter life sciences echo
plate
our original gene fragment product was
the g
they were the first commercially
available fragments launched
in 2012. these were designed for gene
construction
ngs controls and qpcr controls and
standards
the real benefit in qpcr is the ability
to compile
to combine multiple amplicons in a
single fragment
therefore ensuring uniform concentration
in your assay
and also that you can have synthetic
amplicons for those orthologs that
you're not able to find
in nature these range from 125 to 3 000
bases and they delivered in two to eight
business days
again these are available in a variety
of different formats
the final product i want to mention
before moving on to the new product is
our custom gene synthesis service
we offer custom clonal genes from 25 to
5
000 bases these are ngs verified and
available in either a standard idt
vector
or your own custom vector
one thing to mention is that there are
no hidden cloning fees when you order
our custom gene synthesis services
so i'm very pleased to announce the
imminent launch of a new product
in our fragment family range
the g blocks hi-fi gene fragments offer
the industry's lower
lowest error rate um one in twelve
thousand
they are double-stranded dna available
from one thousand to three thousand
bases and delivered in six to ten
business days
these fragments are ngs verified
and just to summarize the products in
our fragment family
we have the e-blocks designed for speed
which are particularly suitable as i
mentioned for antibody
protein engineering vaccine development
or high throughput screening
we have our g-blocks gene fragments
which are available
in tubes or in plates these are
particularly suitable for gene
construction qpcr standards and
ngs controls and we also have
our g-blocks hi-5g fragments the newest
product
to the family which are the highest
quality fragments
and suitable for large gene construction
including pathway development
or microbe design one thing that's
universal across all of the fragments
within the family and with any
uh synthetic dna fragments is the
potential
issues when synthesizing these and there
are a number of complexities that should
be avoided
in particular things like secondary
structure hair pins
or extremes of gc repeats and
homopolymeric runs
and this is particularly important near
the terminal ends of a sequence
idt we offer a variety of solutions for
the optimization
and design of your double stranded
fragments to ensure
fast and high quality delivery
so the hi-fi g-box high-five fragments
show the lowest screening effort to find
the correct clone
we found that there's a greater than 90
percent chance of
finding the correct colony when using
the hi-fi fragments
as you can see here in this table a
comparison between
the new hi-fi fragments other suppliers
and the products
already within our portfolio
so here's some data showing cloning
success with the g-box hi-fi fragment
as you can see the predicted cloning
efficiency on the left
as the length increases the predicted
success
decreases but because of the
exceptionally low error rates in the
production of gbox hi-fi gene fragments
the predicted success of cloning is
higher than when similar other fragments
are used
on the right you can see that the g
blocks hi-fi gene fragments offer over
90 percent cloning efficiency
while other fragment products are below
80.
just to summarize the g blocks hi-fi
gene fragments
designed for large gene construction
pathway development or microbe design
are the highest fidelity and the purest
double-stranded fragments available in
the industry
you pick 50 fewer colonies to get your
gene of interest
and they're flexible for all downstream
cloning methods
including golden gate gibson restriction
cloning
there are no universal linkers to remove
so they're come
ready to use and they ship dry or
normalized in tubes or plates
including the beckman call to life
sciences echo plate
so here is an example of how those
fragments are assembled
using the echo acoustic liquid handler
so in this example double-stranded dna
fragments
were designed with overhangs and then
using the new england bio labs
any builder hi-fi dna assembly cloning
kit
you're able to assemble those into a
large construct
the basic principle is that
the proprietary five prime exonuclear
exonuclease digest the overlaps and
create
overhangs the complementary three-prime
overhangs are then filled with a dna
polymerase upon annealing
dna ligase is used on the final product
to seal mix
and create a continuous assembly the
entire reaction is incubated at a
temperature of 50 celsius
for as little as 15 minutes in a
recommended volume
of 20 microliters
the synthetic biology products and
integrated dna technologies
are assembled with the echo acoustic
liquid handler echo 525
this allows us to rapidly deliver eblox
gene fragments
in as little as one business day it
reduces the reaction volume
by as much as 48 times versus
traditional liquid
handlers and as i mentioned previously
sustainability is key
to synthetic biology it's a big focus
for a lot of the companies and the
researchers active in this
in this space and echo acoustic liquid
handler saves us
over three million plastic tips per year
but integrated dna technologies we're
committed to minimizing the
environmental impacts of our
manufacturing research operations
and our products and services and we're
continuously working to improve those
through the applications and use of new
technologies like the beckman life
sciences
acoustic liquid handlers we've also
integrated
a number of sustainable features into
our headquarters building in coralville
iowa
this includes geothermal heating and
cooling
use of recycled building materials the
application of energy efficient
equipment
and solar shading to allow natural light
without increasing heat load
we also use storm water bios whales
prairie glasses
that naturally filter the parking lot
run-off
so to summarize idt is a complete
product line to support synthetic
biology research
we have a history of sustainable
automation of high throughput workflows
it coupled with the beckman quarter life
sciences echo acoustic liquid handler
this is an enabling technology that
allows us to supply our customers
worldwide with consistent quality
products
and with reliable turnaround times and
we're very pleased to announce
the imminent launch of the new g blocks
hi-fi gene fragments
that are perfect for a wide range of
applications
and will hopefully drive synthetic
biology forward
over the coming years thank you very
much for your time today
i look forward to questions thank you
thank you sahela and tom for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question is
does the echo require calibrating for
each fluid type
echo has some preset calibrations and
all user needs to do
is pick one of the preset calibrations
that is a short list so
no user calibration at the machine
is required or even possible
great thank you okay next question is
what volume are g blocks re-suspended in
when shipped an echo 384 well plate
thank you that's a good question um we
resuspend our g-blocks hi-fi fragments
in a volume of 50 microliters at a
concentration of 20 nanograms per
microliter
this is true for the echo 384 well
plates and also for our other
shipping formats for tubes and our 96 or
384 well pcr plates
thank you for that okay now this next
question
asks can you use any type of plate with
the echo
you can use any destination plates that
are spss standard and automation
friendly of course
on echo so that's really a wide range of
plates
on this source plates because they want
to ensure of
a great quality of transfers we
require users to use our echo source
plates
that are variety of plates available to
the users
thanks so hayla now tom i think this
question is for you
can i amplify can i amplify my g
blocks if i need more yield
this is a question i get quite often
actually so for most applications
the material that we provide is ready
for use and at a sufficient yield
the pcr amplification shouldn't really
be necessary
however if you do wish to amplify g
blocks smaller than 1kb
standard g blocks then we would
recommend using the minimum amount of
starting template required by your pcr
kit protocol
and limit the cycles to 10 to 12 using a
high fidelity polymerase
if you have sequences longer than 1kb
then we strongly recommend you purchase
the gbox hi-fi fragments and follow the
same procedure
these are designed really for assembling
uh or
they're much more designed for
amplification
and for the assembly of very large
constructs due to the very low error
rate
thanks tom now how do i design my g
blocks for restriction cloning
okay yeah when you're cloning uh g block
gene fragments
uh it's very similar to cloning a very
pure pcr
product one important thing to remember
is to add
six to eight bases at the ends of your
fragments
but on the restriction recognition
sequences most enzymes won't cut
efficiently
if at all if the fragment terminates
precisely at the restriction site so do
remember to add those extra bases
in your design
so let's go ahead and move over to you
how does the ecosystem
sorry how does the ecosystem ensure
there is no cross contamination
that's a good question and that's the
one that we get often
so between the source and destination
plate
that as you know destination plate is
inverted on top of the source plate
between them there is only 0.5
millimeter gap so they are really close
to each other
and the drops um are transferred to the
center
of the destination plate so when
users choose the right calibration which
is a wide calibration
it's not just specific to a specific
liquid it's a wide calibration
covering wide range of liquid properties
the drops end up in the center of the
destination plate and that's how we
ensure of
no cross-contamination
now if the destination's destination is
inverted
why doesn't the liquid fall out of the
wells
that's another common question we get
thanks for asking that
so i know it may sound
a little strange but surface tension
does wonders
and the liquid actually sticks to the
destination plate
upside down up to a large amount of
volume for example
with water or with solutions that have
high surface tension like glycerol
and we can hold upside down maybe
40-50 microliters depending on the
coating on the destination plate
but those are not uncommon volumes that
we
hold upside down based on surface
tension holding the liquid
but now if you have detergents that
volume will reduce
great thank you
what length of overlap region do you
recommend for gibson
assembly
i'm guessing that one's probably for me
um
so yeah we we generally recommend
overlaps of between around 30 to 80
80 base pairs for gibson in general
using
using overlaps longer than 35 base pairs
is recommended
for larger constructs particularly those
greater than 3kb
or when you're assembling three or more
fragments
um we have a full gibson assembly
protocol available on idt dna.com
and also new england bio labs neb hi-fi
builder kits also have a very specific
protocol that will help you with that
can the echo be used to transfer live
cells
absolutely and this is also a common
question
echo uses very gentle ultrasounds and
and the drops are big enough that cells
actually fit in a drop
and we do a very gentle transfer of the
cells and those are some of the very
common applications that echo is used
for
great thank you now how long would it
take to transfer 2 microliters from a
384w
plate to another 384w plate on echo
to transfer from a 384 source plate to a
384 destination plate one by one
from let's say a one of the source plate
on
one plate to another well in the
destination plate one by one from each
well
it will take only two minutes on echo
five to five
great thank you now we have time for
just a few more questions
thomas questions for you can i directly
transfect
g blocks into mammaline cells
uh that's a great question as well yeah
these these are really good questions so
g
blocks and the g blocks hi-fi gene
fragments are suitable for direct
transfection
um there's a few things to consider
though we do recommend filter
sterilization
with a 0.22 micron filter before use
some researchers have observed toxicity
in cells when you transfect large
amounts of double
double stranded dna that sensitivity
does vary
depending on which cell line you're
working on so we do suggest titrating
concentrations
of the double-stranded fragments just to
determine what that optimal delivery
will be
for your particular cell type
great thank you and our last question is
how many colony spots have you tried
spotting
on the sbs omni trays
that's a good question so we safely
transfer 1536 spot spots on
an lb agar plate that is a standard size
and like those omni trays you mentioned
but
it doesn't mean that if we push for it
we cannot go higher but 1536 is a safe
number
thank you again sahil and tom do you
have any final comments for our audience
before we go
i wanted to invite the audience to feel
free to reach out to us with any of
their simple to complex gene assembly
projects and let us be part of their
solution
yeah absolutely uh as sahela says you
know please do contact us with any
questions or if there's anything we can
do to help and i'd just like to say
thank you again to everybody for joining
us today
and to our host lavree and our sponsors
beckman call to life science
it's been a pleasure speaking to you
thank you
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank
sohaila and tom for their time today
and for their important research we
would also like to thank labrutz and our
sponsor beckman culture life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye